bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi une journée de fête à millau
jacques chirac a inauguré le viaduc long
milieu des 2000 ouvriers du chantier cet
ouvrage est le symbole d'une france qui
réussit a dit le chef de l'état
image réaction et trois questions à marc
legrand a qui était en charge de la
construction bonsoir et à tout à l'heure
on évoquera notamment la résistance du
viaduc
quatre ans après le crash du concorde à
gonesse la justice met en cause un
défaut de fabrication dans l'avion les
réservoirs étaient mal protégés et tout
le monde le savait une note écrite dès
1979 évoquait déjà un risque d'accident
elle ne sera plus tout à fait la grande
muette l'armée française assoupli le
statut des militaires pour attirer plus
de monde
les soldats pourront désormais
s'exprimer sans autorisation mais le
confidentiel défense demeure et le droit
de grève reste interdite coup de
tonnerre au chili ch la justice a décidé
finalement d'inculper augusto pinochet
pour l'élimination d'opposants dans les
années 70 l'ex dictateur a également été
placée en résidence surveillée il a fait
appel
encore une preuve de la présence d'eau
ou de glace sur mars
le petit robot spirit poursuit ses
explorations il a identifié un minéral
qui ne se forme quand présence d'eau
enfin dix jours de noël les nouvelles
tendances côté parfum des senteurs de
celluloïd tout un mélange de rose et de
truffe noire les créateurs les plus
célèbres relance des éditions limitées
individualisé est plutôt audacieuse
c'est très cher et paraît-il très
branché pour commencer donc l'image qui
clôt cette journée amelio c'était il ya
quelques minutes le viaduc illuminer les
haubans et les rambardes ont d'abord été
éclairés
puis les feux de bengale placé sur toute
la longueur du tablier ont été allumés
et la fête vous ne voyez s'est achevée
par un feu d'artifice pour terminer en
beauté cette inauguration
toute la journée le pont qui enjambe la
vallée du tarn a vu défiler les invités
on s'est beaucoup congratuler jacques
chirac a été le premier à traverser le
pont en voiture ce matin le président de
la république a donc couronné trois ans
de travaux titanesques le viaduc est
maintenant prêt à entrer en service
reportage véronique symbolise comme dans
un film
la voiture du président de la république
s'avance lentement ce matin sur le
viaduc de millau le plus beau le plus
haut du monde
un viaduc au superlatif
le président de la république est à la
fête les ouvriers du chantier les élus
relais spectateurs tout le monde célèbre
aujourd'hui le génie français aux
couleurs de la patrouille de france
dans la salle des fêtes c'est la
bousculade des grands jours jacques
chirac qui est arrivé avec alain juppé
multiplie les marques d'affection
ostentatoire à son égard
l'euphorie
star qui porte bien son nom est lié à la
fois une très grande élégance quand on
voit dans bad millau c'est presque un
trait de plume en même temps une
sentiment de force si la réputation des
entreprises françaises le développement
de toute la région
les grands projets d'infrastructures
avec le viaduc de millau le chef de
l'état célèbre la france une france
entreprenante et qui réussit une france
qui investit dans l'avenir une france
aux avant-postes du progrès banque
mondiale une france à la pointe de
l'excellence scientifique et technique
après ces deux heures d'inauguration en
grande pompe le viaduc de millau sera
ouvert pour tous jeudi prochain alors il
y avait les élus les dirigeants il y
avait aussi on les a vus les casques
blancs ingénieurs contremaître ouvriers
ils ont passé des jours et des nuits sur
le chantier et ils ont essuyé une petite
larme léo lamberton parce qu'elles
pensent pour les ouvriers qui ont
construit le viaduc
c'est la consécration à la surprise de
tous le président de la république est
venu se mêler à eux pour les féliciter
c'est un grand jour s'est fait que
jonathan pourquoi sarah lisant notre
travail et puis c'est un renversement
pour tout le monde les 600 ouvriers
présents sur le viaduc ce matin j fk une
première d'habitude il ne participe pas
aux inaugurations
mais on ne construit pas tous les jours
le plus haut pont du monde sur un petit
peu des piles ou vision
la noire que c'est une opération la
république ça ça vous émeut en trois ans
de travaux les ouvriers ont vécu
beaucoup de moments forts notamment le
28 mai dernier lors de la jonction des
deux ponts du tablier
beaucoup d'ailleurs ont quitté le
chantier à cette époque et ce matin lors
des retrouvailles
certains comme jean yves électricien
était le fer de poules avec sap la
naissance de mon fils ouais ça change
inoubliable vous le dire je crois dans
sa vie je crois que c'est le seul salle
dernier je pense à d'autres ne sont pas
revenus depuis le début du chantier il
le découvre aujourd'hui fini on a fait
depuis lon le p6 t5 et on a faim on a
bossé sur l'établi aussi et alors là bas
c'est impressionnant ce soir en partant
les ouvriers savent qu'ils se
retrouveront bientôt sur d'autres
chantiers
mais le viaduc de millau restera l'une
de leurs plus belles aventures
mais jusque-là bio était la capitale des
gants en cuir et du roquefort et
désormais c'est le viaduc qui sera
l'emblème de la ville depuis trois ans
des centaines de milliers de touristes
sont d'ailleurs venus admirer le site
qui fait aussi la fierté des habitants
lnv angel lopez
certains l'ont photographié sous toutes
les coutures d'autres encore sont restés
sans voix mais jamais le viaduc ne les a
laissés indifférents
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est une technique là que je comprends
même pas bon je pense qu'il ne tombera
pas sa solide on a l'impression de voir
un avion décoller oiseaux c'est pendant
très beau et du viaduc aujourd'hui c'est
c'est quelque chose d'unique et qu'on a
envie d'immortaliser comme de loin de
près jusqu'au pied de l'ouvragé
chacun cherche sa place pour la
meilleure vue surtout lorsque la route
est longue
340 km
pourquoi pour voir cette merveille un
chef-d'oeuvre connu dans le monde entier
jusqu'à la télévision russe qui a fait
le déplacement
je veux dire que les télés ses passions
pour les constructeurs pour le pour les
habitants qui habitent là alors
félicitations et c'est vrai qu'à millau
les habitants sont particulièrement
fiers de leurs viaduc et ils le disent
c'est magnifiquement jeudi les gens qui
vont descendre dans le midi mais en un
clin d'oeil un passage on est passé sous
viaduc gpj croit 2001-2005 millau gagne
un viaduc et entre dans l'histoire
voilà j'espère qu'il ne tombera pas
disait l'un des visiteurs bonsoir marc
legrand s'interroge effectivement sur la
sécurité de l'édifice
vous allez nous parler de sa longévité
et de sa résistance au vent par exemple
d'abord on l'a beaucoup dit rappelant
qu'il s'agit du pont suspendu le plus
haut du monde
mais jusqu'à quand car la course au
gigantisme est bien engagé toujours plus
haut plus loin plus grand nicolas
chateauneuf patrice pollet
c'est un ouvrage aux dimensions
pharaoniques un chef-d'oeuvre
d'ingénieurs qu aurait sans doute
apprécié à sa juste valeur les grands
bâtisseurs de l'antiquité et en premier
lieu les romains maîtres incontestés des
ponts en pierre comme ici le pont du
gard depuis 2000 ans la garantie court
toujours
le secret la technique de la clé de
voûte une pierre taillée qui maintient
l'équilibré des charges
mais si elle cède tout s'effondre il
faudra attendre 1800 ans pour que la
révolution industrielle viennent tous
balayés à la fin du 19e siècle
l'acier des trolls lapierre le monde se
couvrent de pompe comme ici à garabit en
france ou plus tard à sydney avec le
vingtième siècle apparaît un nouveau
matériau le béton et avec lui les
premiers ponts suspendus comme ici le
pont de tancarville encore plus grand
encore plus long dans ce cas deux tiges
soutiennent le tablier
mais le modèle a ses limites en 1940 le
pont de tacoma aux états unis se mettent
à se tordre le vent n'est que de 70
kilomètres heure mais le pont finira par
an la leçon retenue les ingénieurs vont
repousser les limites physiques
le plus bel exemple est le golden gate à
san francisco puis vient l'heure des
ponts à haubans
c'est la technique utilisée pour le pont
de normandie et le viaduc de millau
difficile de faire plus grand il faudra
nécessairement introduire de nouvelles
avancées technologiques de à faire
apparaître de nouveaux matériaux et on
pense dès à présent aux matériaux
composites et notamment aux suspensions
en fibre de carbone des techniques qui
seront utiles pour le plus grand projet
les prochaines années le pont de messine
qui doit relier la sicile à l'italie
380 mètres de haut à 3700 mètres de long
un ouvrage incroyable dont le chantier
de six ans de débuter l'année prochaine
seul souci il faudra trouver 6 milliards
d'euros voilà restons à millau pour
l'instant avec celui qui a supervisé le
chantier marc legrand directeur général
d'eiffage première question est ce que
c'est le chantier le plus complexe le
plus compliqué que vous ayez eu à gérer
c'est incontestablement un chantier très
technique et en particulier on peut
parler du système que nous avons breveté
pour mettre en place le tablier
mais je crois qu'avant tout et vous
l'avait bien montré il faut souligner la
formidable motivation de nos équipes qui
ont travaillé souvent dans des
conditions difficiles car il a fallu
travailler de nuit et par le froid alors
est ce que c'est un viaduc absolument
sûrs et à quelle vitesse devant peut-il
résister est ce qu'il faudra le fermer
parfois si le vent est trop fort le
viaduc résistera des vents qui
dépasserait 250 km heure jeudi
dépasserait car les vents les plus forts
jamais observé à millau ont été de 176
kilomètres heure dont vous voyez
nous avons un grand coefficient de
sécurité et nous l'avons munis d'écrans
brise vent ce qui veut dire que pour les
voitures ce ne sera pas différent de la
situation observée de part et d'autre
sur les plateaux ouais elle ne sentiront
pas le vent qu'elle est la longévité
l'édifice on parle de 120 ans je crois
qu'il est assurée pour cent vingt ans
est ce que ça signifie que pendant cent
vingt ans rien ne va bouger ou est-ce
qu'il faudra remplacer des pièces un peu
comme sur une voiture
il faudra faire de l'entretien courant
et par exemple peut-être changer
quelques au banc bien sûr refaire la
chaussée
mais en fait vous savez cent vingt ans
c'est une garantie contractuelle dans la
réalité donnons nous rendez vous dans
trois cents dans 400 années et je suis
sûr que le viaduc de millau sera encore
là merci monsieur le grand rendez vous
est pris en attendant le viaduc sera
donc ouvert la circulation après demain
et on referme ce chapitre avec une autre
originalité de cet ouvrage l'état n'y a
pas mis un sou il a été entièrement
financé par l'entreprise qui en assure
la construction puis l'exploitation
explications stéphane despinoy le coût
du viaduc est à la hauteur de l ouvrage
vertigineux 394 millions d'euros un coût
égal à 10 airbus a318 une somme financée
à 100% par le privé c'est une première
l'état a concédé l'ouvragé pour 75 ans
même si le viaduc et garantissant 20 ans
la société eiffage qui l'a construit
exploitera ce tronçon d'autoroute
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2000 79 pour
franchir la vallée du tarn
les automobilistes vont donc acquitter
les péages 4 euros 90 en basse saison 6
euros 50 en période estivale pour
échapper aux fameux bouchon de millau
enfin le tarif s'élèvera à 20 euros pour
les camions ce sera le seul tronçon à
péage existant sur l'a75 entre clermont
ferrand et béziers après la mise en
service du viaduc
il ne restera plus qu'à ouvrir le
tronçon de lodève et les automobilistes
pourront parcourir les 350 km de
traversée du massif central
sans quitter la mairie d'hyères voilà et
on y reviendra bien entendu demain et
après demain à l'occasion de l'ouverture
à la circulation
autre titre de cette journée c'est
dernier élément dans l'enquêté sur le
crash du concorde à gonesse il ya quatre
ans accident qui avait fait 113 morts le
parquet a donc révélé le rapport
d'expertisé aujourd'hui et on apprend
qu'ils pointent un défaut important de
l'appareil plus surprenant ce défaut qui
concerne la protection des réservoirs
étaient connus depuis très longtemps
des incidents avaient même était déjà
signalé zine dine boudaoud vincent
bouffartigue les proches des victimes du
crash du concorde sont impatients de
connaître la vérité
ces deux femmes sont la veuve et la
soeur du commandant de bord pas ce qui
m'intéresse c'est surtout pas vu deux
des pilotes savoir qu'ils ne soient pas
qui est pas une responsabilité qu'on
essaie leur remettre permettre d'en
faire porter quatre ans après les faits
les familles des victimes ont pris
connaissance des conclusions de
l'enquêté le procureur de la république
de pontoise les a révélés à la presse
aucun doute pour la justice l'accident a
bien été provoquée de façon directe par
cette lamelle une pièce mécanique perdue
par un dc10 de continental airlines
quatre minutes avant le décollage du
concorde l'enchaînement des faits connus
le concorde a roulé sur cette pièce un
pneumatique a explosé et des projections
percé le réservoir qui a fini par
prendre feu
il ya bien un lien de causalité directe
entre l'accident et le crash qui a coûté
la vie à 113 personnes et est le défaut
de continental airlines défaut puisque
la lame n'aurait jamais dû être en
titane mais dans un acier - trempé la
compagnie américaine se dit scandalisé
par sa mise en cause plusieurs salariés
et leurs dirigeants sans pourtant bien
convoqué par la justice française
mais d'autres responsabilités sans
pointer un défaut important du concorde
avait été repérée dès 1979
une note de service saisis par la
justice imaginez même le scénario
catastrophe vécue le 25 juillet cette
note recommander des modifications
techniques
elle est restée lettre morte on avait
préconisé du câble art en 1981 et qu'on
l'a mis après 2000
pourquoi ne l'at-on pas mis à l'époque
c'est une question pourquoi de la tourbe
amis à l'époque et pourquoi l'at-on me
après après l'accident de juillet 2000
les conclusions des experts sont donc
lourdes accusations
il revient au juge d'instruction dans
tirez maintenant toutes les conséquences
et pas de réaction pour l'instant de la
direction générale de l'aviation civile
la dg assez justice encore le mystère
demeure sur les circonstances de la mort
de géraldine giraud et katia lherbier
les premiers résultats de l'autopsié
indiquent qu'il n'y a eu ni et touche
mans ni empoisonnement et puis dans le
même temps le comédien roland giraud
s'exprime dans un billet publié dans
paris match
il demande à la presse aux journalistes
de respecter le secret d'instruction
pour ne pas troubler l'enquète yann
fronty virginie travers
c'est le message d'un homme blessé comme
il se qualifie lui-même silencieux
depuis le début de la sphère roland
giraud s'exprime pour la première fois
dans un texte publié demain par paris
match
je demande humblement à tous les
journalistes que je respecte de penser
uniquement à la mémoire si précieuse de
géraldine et katia et de ne pas troubler
cette enquête si délicate
quatre jours après la découverte des
corps dans ce puits de villeneuve sur
yonne
l'autopsié n'a toujours pas révélé les
causes de la mort des deux jeunes femmes
les premières analyses ont seulement
permis d'écarter des hypothèses
géraldine et katia n'ont pas été tués
par arme à feu ni par arme blanche
leurs corps ne présentent aucune trace
de strangulation d'étouffement ni
d'empoisonnement des examens
complémentaires sont en cours
quant au principal suspect jean pierre
treiber il devrait être entendu par le
juge d'instruction en début de semaine
prochaine
un virage pour l'armée française
confrontée à des difficultés de
recrutement elle a décidé d'assouplir le
statut des militaires
ils pourront désormais s'exprimer
librement mais à condition de respecter
le secret défense
ils pourront aussi présider une
association c'est la fin progressive de
la grande muette
samah soula jean-jacques le garrec
actions de proximité clip télévisé
l'armée multiplie ses opérations
séduction pour attirer de nouvelles
recrues
elle propose trente mille emplois chaque
année
mais les volontaires membres cet
assouplissement du statut des militaires
complète cette volonté de donner une
image plus moderne plus ouverte de
l'institution avec la réforme soldats
sous-officiers officiers pourront
publier un livre un article parlait à la
presse sans autorisation préalable de
leur hiérarchie ils pourront prendre la
parole mais avec une certaine modération
on leur demande finalement une forme
d'autorégulation comme ils sont pas
contrôlés avant ils ne seront peut être
après s'il ya des problèmes à leur
demande donc une certaine maîtrise dans
l'expression du gerb au goût de
l'écriture de façon à ne pas dépasser
les bornes en matière de critique sur
les terrains d'opération le secret
militaire sera bien sûr toujours de mise
si réforme il ya nos soldats pourront
aussi se marier avec un étranger ou
présider une association
en revanche il leur sera toujours
interdit de faire grève d'adhérer à un
parti politique ou un syndicat
voilà et si vous ne souhaitez pas vous
engager dans l'armée et bien vous faites
peut-être partie d un million et demi de
français qui travaillent à la maison
généralement sur ordinateur cela
s'appelle le télétravail du travail à
distance sans jamais passer par le
bureau ou seulement de temps en temps le
gouvernement vient de se voir remettre
un rapport sur le sujet pour mieux
réglementer ce secteur
martin gwen yvan martineau
16h30 miguel membrado fait une pause
dans son travail chef d'entreprise il
est allé chercher ses enfants à l'école
et ensuite retour à son bureau
une dizaine de marches plus tard il est
dans son entreprise sous les combles de
sa maison une société qui se développe
sur internet et qui lui permet
d'équilibrer vie de famille et vie
professionnelle
cet équilibre vie de famille vie
professionnelle savait vraiment été
salle au départ qui a initié cette
volonté d'être en télétravail savoir
travailler à la maison est un des
critères d'embauché dans sa société
car même les réunions se font chez soi
par caméras interposées
ouais on tout va très bien en tout cas
de problème on n'a pas perdu chacun 2h
ou 3h de déplacement pour rien donc la
réunion elle-même elle est tout à fait
opérationnels sont pour seront
opérationnels et les plus sollicités le
télétravail concerne pour le moment
principalement les ingénieurs les cadres
et en majorité les hommes il est encore
confidentiel en france seulement sept
salariés sur 100 le font régulièrement
contre 12 sur 100 au danemark et en
europe du nord
cette méthode de travail n'a pas encore
la cote dans les entreprises et à
l'adage qu'on connaît bien loin des yeux
loin du coeur qui peut faire que l'on
peut penser que certains managers
pourrait avoir une appréhension en
développement du télétravail
un travail d'un nouveau genre qui permet
à miguel membrado de travailler à sa
convenance
sans compter les heures qu'il consacre à
son entreprise
en bref encore à propos d' économie deux
informations la semaine dernière les
viticulteurs organisaient une
manifestation sans précédent dans les
grandes villes de france on en avait
parlé ici même et bien représentants ont
été reçus par le ministre de
l'agriculture dominique bussereau pas
d'indication pour l'instant sur les
résultats de cette entrevue les
viticulteurs s'inquiète vous le savez la
concurrence étrangère il souhaite aussi
un assouplissement de la loi evin sur la
publicité
et puis sachez que la commission
européenne a décidé de suspendre les
procédures contre la france et
l'allemagne procédures entamées contre
des déficits budgétaires excessifs
bruxelles estime que paris et berlin
sont en bonne voie pour revenir dans la
norme
rebondissement judiciaire au chili où la
justice fait face à l'histoire
l'ex dictateur augusto pinochet a
finalement été inculpé et placé en
résidence surveillée jusqu'à présent il
avait échappé aux tribunaux parce qu'il
était considéré comme sénile bertrand
cote à 89 ans le général pinochet n'en a
pas fini avec le passé le dictateur à la
retraite qui compte encore de nombreux
partisans au chili se retrouve à nouveau
inculpé et placé en résidence surveillée
par son vieil ennemi le juge bousman
tapia en 2002 une première procédure
avait fait long feu la cour suprême
ayant jugé pinochet mentalement
incapable de se défend cette fois ci le
vieux cas odillo est poursuivi pour des
crimes commis sous son régime lors de
l'opération condor ce programme mis en
oeuvre dans les années 70 par différents
dictateurs sud-américains pour éliminer
leurs opposants de gauche et d'extrême
gauche
ça fait 15 ans que la justice court
après pinochet on se souvient qu'en 2000
le général était rentré chez lui sur ses
deux jambes
à l'issue de 500 jours de détention à
domicile en angleterre libéré déjà pour
raisons de santé
aujourd'hui les familles des milliers de
victimes et de disparus de la dictature
manifestent leur joie et leur confiance
dans la justice chilienne
quel magnifique cadeau de noël 17
avocats
un cadeau pour tous les chiliens qui ont
lutté afin que justice se fasse
c'est un grand jour pour les chiliens
aujourd'hui nous sommes un peu plus
démocrates mais les avocats du vieux
général n'ont pas épuisé toutes les
ressources de la procédure
ils ont déposé un recours suspensif
devant la cour d'appel
en attendant à augusto pinochet qui
s'est toujours refusé à exprimer le
moindre remord profite de ses petits
enfants dans sa propriété des environs
de santiago un débat très vif à
l'assemblée nationale tout à l'heure à
48 heures du sommet européen sur
l'ouverture de négociations avec la
turquie
confronté à un feu roulant de questions
à droite comme à gauche
michel barnier le chef de la diplomatie
française a indiqué que le résultat de
la négociation si elle est engagée mais
croisé creed avance il a également
précisé que la reconnaissance par ankara
du génocide arménien on en parlait tiers
n'est pas une condition à l'ouverture de
ces discussions
comme chaque soir nous livrons un
élément d'appréciation à hier on a parlé
histoire et géographie aujourd'hui nous
évoquons la question religieuse
en clair peut-on doit-on intégré dans
une union européenne chrétienne par son
histoire et sa pratique
quelque 70 millions de musulmans gilles
rabin et midi dansant
les turcs font peur et c'est normal
pendant des siècles l'empiré ottoman a
lancé ses troupes à la conquête de
l'europe
la forteresse chrétienne et il a failli
réussir à siéger encore vienne
l'autrichienne à la fin du xviie siècle
aujourd'hui bien sûr la menace islamique
a changé elle a pris le visage de ben
laden et d'al qaïda mais il y à débat la
grande erreur c'est de croire qu'il ya
un islam unique et de considérer qu en
ouvrant la porte à la turquie en gros on
fait entrer l'islam en europe nous ont
fait entrer les turcs en europe
la frontière n'est pas tout à fait
étanche entre l'islamisme modéré et
l'islamisme terroriste puisque dans les
deux cas ce sont des gens qui adhèrent à
un islam anti libérale et
antidémocratique
pourtant la turquie est un cas unique
dans l'histoire une république laïque
depuis 1923 et la révolution de mustafa
kemal atatürk qui a imposé à son pays
des valeurs occidentales
c'est une chance historique c'est mais
de le démontrer à tout le monde à nous
occidentaux également reste du monde
musulman qu'il est parfaitement possible
de faire coexister les idées
républicaines et la civilisation
musulmane je pense la turquie n'a pas
changé c'est une turquie ni aux
islamistes néo ottomane qui veulent en
découdre avec la laïcité
ce sont des gens qui je le rappelle sont
pour l'interdiction d'alcool de
cigarettes ils voulaient punir aussi le
flirt pas uniquement l'adultère la
turquie cheval de troie islamistes dans
l'europe c'est la grande peur de ceux
qui militent contre son entrée dans
l'union européenne
or et des frontières avec les zones les
plus dangereuses du monde qui sont en
plus les gens du djihad et qui sont en
moyenne orient ou en asie centrale dans
le caucase perception complètement
différente chez ceux qui pensent que la
turquie est une chance pour l'europe la
turquie aujourd'hui un un gouvernement
démocrate musulman comme nous avons eu
en europe pendant très longtemps des
gouvernements démocrates chrétiens l'une
porte le foulard islamique l'autre pas
et pourtant elles sont soeurs c'est là
des nombreux paradoxes de la turquie
moderne et c'est pourquoi elle inquiète
et puis toujours à propos d'europe
la révision de la constitution qui doit
précéder le référendum sur la
constitution européenne
eh bien on a appris que cette révision
serait discutée les 25 26 et 27 janvier
à l'assemblée en irak ce rappel
quotidien nos confrères christian
chesnot et georges malbrunot sont
retenus en otage depuis 117 jours
maintenant
et puis un mot de la chaîne al manar
elle n'est plus diffusées par eutelsat
la chaîne de télévision du hezbollah
libanais a cessé volontairement des
maîtres via l'opérateur satellite
eutelsat
elle se conforme ainsi à la décision
prise hier par le conseil d'état par la
justice française aux etats unis cette
nouvelle méthode contre les vols de
voitures là bas aussi c'est un fléau et
bien les américains ont inventé la
voiture appât les portes sont ouvertes
parfois même on laisse les clés sur le
contact c'est pour mieux surveiller puis
arrêté les voleurs
et apparemment le piège est efficace
pascal golomer restant lebrun à new york
plutôt contents de leur coup une voiture
volée sans effraction avec les clés sur
le contact
rien de plus facile mais trop beau pour
être vrai quelques minutes plus tard
changement d'ambiance
la police est à leurs trousses la cavale
est terminée c'est une voiture piégée
dit le conducteur qui est j'ai
effectivement avec micros et caméras
incorporé l'auteur du stratagème c'est
lui le fils iwan johnson depuis six ans
avec son équipe
oui ces mines un peu partout dans
minneapolis des voitures a pas comme ils
les appellent parce qu'elles sont
censées attirer les cambrioleurs ce
matin ils déplacent l'une d'entre elles
qui n'a pas eu au cours de la semaine
passée le succès escompté
pourtant dans une ville où 3500 voitures
sont volés chaque année le choix du lieu
de stationnement n'est jamais le fruit
du hasard si on remarque qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de vols dans un quartier donné
on essaie de placer là bas le type de
véhicule qui correspond à ce que
recherchent les voleurs retour à
l'atelier dans un entrepôt très discret
c'est là que wayne johnson nous présente
sa botte secrète
un petit boîtier caché dans le coffre
qui envoie un signal aux centrales de
police dès que quelqu'un ouvre la porte
de la voiture
la caméra grosse comme une tête
d'épinglé filmé la scène jusqu'à
l'arrestation la cassette servira de
pièces à conviction au moment du
français
la méthode un autre avantage éviter ces
fameuses courses poursuites je suis
friand les télévisions américaines
mais qui peuvent être meurtrières pour
les voleurs comme pour les pauvres
automobilistes qui se trouvent sur leur
chemin
one johnson lui peut pister ses voitures
piégées grâce à des balises gps embarqué
à bord
l'arrestation est un jeu d'enfant le
système couvre tous les états unis et le
canada ou que partent les voleurs on les
retrouve à ce jour il n'y a pas
d'urgence 50 arrestations encore cette
famille à minneapolis
de nombreuses villes américaines suivent
l'exemple et le font savoir publiquement
pour que les voleurs de voitures
réfléchissent à deux fois avant de
mettre le contact
toujours à propos de voiture mais en
france cette fois l'idée d'une aide au
financement du permis de conduire pour
les jeunes semblent bien progresser
elle avait été évoquée début décembre
elle a été reprise aujourd'hui par
jacques chirac
l'argent des radars automatiques
pourraient être utilisés pour cela à
l'idée c'est aussi de faire diminuer le
nombre de conducteurs sans permis
julia delage frédéric faure le radar
automatique cauchemar des automobilistes
mais bientôt peut-être meilleur ami des
jeunes préfet eux d'obtenir leur permis
de conduire en effet une partie de
l'argent des pv pourrait aider certains
à financer l'examen l'idée est tentante
en un an les radars automatiques ont
rapporté près de 100 millions d'euros
alors que pour les jeunes le coût du
permis environ 1500 euros est de plus en
plus lourd
la majorité des élèves qui passent leur
permis de conduire à 80 % ce sont des
jeunes qui ne sont pas entrés dans la
vie active donc qui n'ont pas les moyens
souvent de ces payer il faut que ce soit
les parents qui les payent quand est en
hausse de 3 ans en basse est président
ça coûte très cher
trop cher même alors solution roulait
sans permis
selon des estimations environ un
conducteur sur dix roulent aujourd'hui
en toute illégalité comme c'est cher
quelque part ça pousse les jeunes un peu
à faire décoller les modalités de ce
dispositif ne sont pas encore totalement
établi d'autant que d'autres sont en
projet comme un livret d'epargne spécial
permis réservé aux mineurs en janvier un
rapport commandé par le premier ministre
devrait faire le point sur les
différentes méthodes d'apprentissage de
la conduite
en bref on évoquait l'arrivée du froid
hier et bien l'hiver qui commence dans
quelques jours a fait un premier mort un
sans abri de 58 ans découvert dans une
grange dans la somme près d'amiens
il a été retrouvé au matin par le
propriétaire des lieux un agriculteur un
important réseau de prostitution et de
blanchiment d'argent a été démantelé à
nantes 44 personnes interpellées une
trentaine de suspects étaient toujours
en garde à vue aujourd'hui l' enquête a
duré 15 mois et c'est l'occasion de
s'interroger sur les lois sarkozy
rappelant qu'elles ont interdit le
racolage passif on en avait beaucoup
parlé à l'époque alors presque deux ans
plus tard qu'en est il eh bien elles ont
provoqué un reflux de la prostitution
mais également un déplacement du
phénomène les prostituées entité les
trottoirs des centres villes pour
s'installer dans des appartements mais
aussi dans les bois où les boulevards à
la périphérie
et si de nombreux proxénètes ont été
arrêtés les réseaux sont toujours actifs
pour les prostituées africaines par
exemple il s'agit souvent de réseaux
familiaux enquête signée mathias hillion
mathias baron 150 camionnette aligner de
jour comme de nuit au bois de vincennes
un espace entre chaque véhicule pour que
les clients puissent se garer des lampes
à pétrole qui transforme la vende ses
estafette en vitrine des prostituées
africaines qui se relaient toutes les
six heures
le système est bien rodé
bonjour comment ça se passe alors qu'est
ce que tu proposes
30 euros des prix cassés pour dépassent
parfois risqué et prennent les gens qui
payent qui travaillent sans capote à
n'importe quelle heure et travaillent
plus que les autres elle vous coûte
moins cher elles font les choses les
plus difficiles
elles viennent de sierra leone du
nigeria ou du cameroun
paris n'est souvent qu'un point de
passage vers la province où la
répression policière est moins forte
mais comme dans la capitale c'est la
prostitution caché qui se développe à
tour dans l'un de ces appartements
elisabeth a dû se prostituer pendant
plusieurs mois son proxénète une femme
qu'elle croyait bien connaître sa
cousine m'a prostitue ça le problème
beaucoup de fuites sommes là dedans
parce que vraiment à l'ol n'ont rien à
manger à son vraiment pauvre et elles
viennent en france pour travailler
l'argent pour envoyer leurs familles est
donc toujours l'espoir de t&d à
t'intégrer en france si dans cet espoir
que tu fais ça elisabeth est une
exception cette camerounaise a réussi à
sortir du réseau
aujourd'hui elle est mariée et gagne sa
vie comme femme de ménage
en témoignant elle veut rompre le tabou
de la prostitution familiale dans la
communauté africaine
ce n'était pas ma famille peut être je
ne serais jamais venu
elles ont utilisé ces liens pour pouvoir
bien me matter 6 mt par rober léger
serait dans la rue
à travailler pour les autres hameaux
prostituées des prostituées qui vivent
dans la crainte de leur mama selon cet
avocat mama c'est le nom donné à ces
femmes proxénètes qui ont payé leur
passage
après leur avoir fait subir des rites de
sorcellerie on vous amène en forêt on
vous conditionnent en vous demandant
vous prend une partie de votre sang on
vous indique que si jamais vous tentez
de ne pas rembourser la dette vaut
risquait de périr donc fondamentalement
on vous conditionne dans vos faveurs
difficile de sortir de ces réseaux
difficile aussi pour les policiers de
les démanteler ces jeunes femmes une
fois qu'elles ont pu racheter leurs
dettes
lord est alors ma main leur proxénète
vont à nouveau et elle pourrait même
faire venir des jeunes femmes et
exploiter les exploitent la procession
de ses chaînes câble donc on est devant
quelque chose qui est un petit peu sans
fond il y a quatre ans de réseau de
prostituées africaines était démantelé
par la police contre 12 en 2003 une
filière qui progresse et rattrapent peu
à peu celles de l'est et des balkans
les sciences encore une preuve de la
présence d'eau ou de glace sur mars le
petit robot spirit poursuit ses
explorations il a identifié un minéral
qui ne se forme quand présence d'eau
frédéric montait à 55 millions de km de
la terre mars etc canyon gigantesque
jusqu'à 8 km de profondeur et une
éternelle question
ce relief at il été formés par des
fleuves ou des mères aujourd'hui le
robot américain spirit apporte une
nouvelle réponse voici un de ses
derniers clichés pris près d'un cratère
on y distingue de nombreux rochers parmi
eux une dot it un minéral composé de fer
d'oxygène et d'hydrogène assez répandu
sur terre y compris en france
s'il est là c'est qu'il ya de l'eau la
goethite est un minéral qui contient de
l'eau dans sa structure cristalline
il ne peut pas se former sans eau c'est
sans doute la preuve la plus importante
de l'existence d'eau sur ce cratère en
mai dernier opportunité un autre robot
américain des niches est déjà rose it
des sédiments rider par une eau salée de
l'eau il en reste peut être encore
cachées dans les entrailles de la
planète
j'arrose ite goethite de preuve de plus
que dans un passé lointain mars n'était
pas cette planète aride balayées par des
tempêtes de poussière à moins 70 degrés
mars la rouge ressembler peut-être à
notre planète bleue
et puisqu'il ya eu de l'eau un dernier
mystère reste à élucider
celui d'une éventuelle vie sur mars
l'environnement avec cette histoire
étonnante les habitants de new york sont
mobilisés pour sauver deux faucons
habitué à la vie en ville le couple de
rapaces et est établie depuis plus de 10
ans sur un gratte ciel les locateurs
n'appréciez pas du tout ils ont fait
détruire le nid françois jullien pieds
noirs il avait la plus belle vue sur new
york le loyer le plus modeste de la
ville mais il a été expulsé ce faucon
new yorkais pêle mêle c'est son surnom
s'étaient installés ici en 1993 au il
n'avait pas choisi le bronx mais la 5e
avenue et ses appartements à 10 millions
de dollars 11 ans de cohabitation avec
les riches propriétaires mais le voisin
plus mais n'est pas assez chic pour le
quartier carcasse de rats et pigeons au
déjeuner résultats réunion copropriété
le volatile et déloger c'est tout new
york qui se sent expulsé au hasard ça
fait vraiment mal au coeur
il a tellement de personnes dans la
ville et dans le monde qui aime les
oiseaux ce faucon a créé une communauté
de passionnés dans la ville
le droit pénal est devenu la mascotte
est l'attraction de new york et pourtant
les new-yorkais sont habitués aux
rapaces en 2003 la ville embauche des
faucons pour chasser les pigeons
jusqu'au drame en plein central park
info qu'on tue un chihuahua pêle-mêle
n'est pas un tueur de chihuahua les
propriétaires culpabiliser offrirait
cent mille dollars pour 1 8 ou 9 mai sur
le toit cette fois en attendant elle
même n'est pas un faucon volage il est
fidèle avec la même compagnie a donné
naissance à 26 petit les futurs
locataires des buildings new-yorkais
à dix jours de noël les nouvelles
tendances côté parfum des senteurs de
celluloïd ou un mélange de rose et de
truffe noire
les créateurs les plus célèbres lance
des éditions limitées individualisé et
semble-t-il assez audacieuse c'est très
cher et très branché estelle colin
jean-louis melun il ne s'agit pas d'un
jeu mais de la naissance d'un tout
nouveau parfum pas 26 juin à la mode
édité à 5 millions d'exemplaires non
mais d'une fragrance qui sera lancée
mondialement 120 euros de pub vivre aux
côtés feuilles le côté drama presque
balles de ping pong en celluloïd
plastique soit un petit quelque chose de
surtout pas bananes des parfums
d'initiés créé par les stars de la
partie mais ces hommes de l'ombre des
nez à qui l'on a donné carte blanche
pour la toute première fois
on ne dit pas bon on fait attention
dépasser patel prier tout ça donc c'est
bien et puis aussi si on fait ça un peu
comme quelque chose comme mots qu'on
aime comme un produit d'art le choix
encore une histoire de nez ou peut-être
d'oreille écoutez muscles ravageur noir
épices angélique sous la pluie dans ce
temple du luxe on cultive la sasp et
coûte que coûte et comment quand on a
envie vins bijoux qui sera différent des
autres il faut mettre le prix mais
s'implique en vaut la peine parce que ça
me donne ne serait pour la journée
chaque année 400 nouveaux parfums sont
lancés sur le marché contre 10 hors
catégorie des parfums hors norme qui
n'ont pas pour mission de plaire à tout
le monde ça plaît à peu de gens mais ça
plaît beaucoup et ce sont des gens qui
vont se parfumer avec le produit qu'ils
auront élu
pour des années ça devienne partie de la
parfumerie d'auteur a depuis fait des
émules chez jarre par exemple on cultive
le goût du secret une seule boutique au
monde et pas un seul indice pour guider
votre choix
je ne vous dirai rien
c'est sûr ici on est bien loin de la
parfumerie de masse est de ces 172 mille
flacons vendus en france chaque jour
cinéma le retour au premier plan
d'ingmar bergman
à 85 ans il le retrouve encore une fois
liv ullmann pour un film intitulé
sarabande toujours le couple est
toujours la famille marie jo juin jean
louis hamelin un document unique une
marc darman 86 ans sur le plateau de son
dernier film embrassant une actrice les
musulmanes sous l'oeil goguenard berland
josephson son double à l'écran et
compagnon de toujours sarabande et la
suite de scènes de la vie conjugale est
une cité on en vient on peut faire
l'amour
ce film choc tournée avec liv ullmann en
1973 gouvernement disséquer avec cynisme
et lucidité la vie de couple trente ans
après leur séparation il reprend les
mêmes acteurs et l'a 63 ans lui 86
marianne vient rendre visite à yoann
retirer en ermite sur une semaine la
femme ces conflits familiaux
l'angoissent au seuil de la mort le
cinéaste parle de sa vie deux ans un
dernier témoin on a partagé tellement de
choses l'amitié à la famille nous avons
une fille ensemble - l'actrice lui le
metteur en scène et puis un jour il m'a
dit tu sais lire ce que tu mens
stradivari je crois c'est la plus belle
chose qu'on m'ait jamais dit elle ce que
nous
chaudhry nancy mercenaires après l'aller
2-2 sarabande sera-t-il le dernier film
d'ingmar bergman comme un testament
poignant qui laisse à ses admirateurs
une idée qui bouleverse i feel man et
devant la porte et tout quand il le fait
à ni'lin les orteils et j'ai eu le
sentiment que c'était la dernière fois
une mort serait sur un plateau berman
vite aujourd'hui reclus sur son île
sarabande sera-t-il le point final d'une
oeuvre immense
il paraît qu'il continue à écrire alors
la disparition de françoise verny on
l'appelait souvent la papesse de
l'édition parce qu'elle découvrait des
talents elle avait travaillé chez
grasset puis chez gallimard avec les
plus grands françoise sagan alexandre
jardin ou encore bernard ans lille henri
lévy entre autres auteurs très nombreux
françoise verny avait 77 ans
la rédaction de france 2 doublement
récompensé aujourd'hui lors du prix
dauphine comme chaque année les
programmes économiques sont primés un
oeil sur la planète consacré à l'éveil
de la chine d'abord a reçu le prix de la
meilleure émission de reportages le
prochain numéro présenté par thierry
thuillier ici à l'image est préparé par
patrick boitet sera consacrée à l'inde
ce sera le 20 décembre noté le déjà et
puis séverine lebrun et arnaud bus ont
reçu le prix du meilleur reportage
social pour leur dossier sur le contrôle
des chômeurs que vous avez pu suivre ici
même dans cette édition il y a quelques
semaines bravo séverine bravo arnaud fin
de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo nathalie rihouet 20h55 à un
classique ce grand chemin avec anémone
et richard bohringer 12h50 dernier
journal jean claude renault dès 6h30
télématin et dans les 4 vérités roland
sicard recevra le président de la
commission européenne josé manuel
barroso en skiff sur ce retour à millau
c'est l'image du jour quand le béton et
le métal forme d'une oeuvre d'art les
feux d'artifice ont été tirés en fin
d'après-midi visible à des dizaines de
kilomètres à la ronde
le conte rappelant le ouvrira aux
automobilistes jeudi matin vers 10
heures à demain